hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
preview the upcoming Yellowjackets
Episode by looking at the promo trailer
and photos and breaking those down and
all the other stuff that's floating
around the internet if you're not into
any of that or wild speculation on what
might happen in Yellowjackets season 2
episode 4 then this video won't be for
you
the episode is titled Old Wounds which
when you're talking about the yellow
jackets survivors of a plane crash in 19
months in the remote Wilderness that
pretty much applies to everyone involved
but also Tai going to visit van and
Lottie cutting her Palm in the exact
same place in both timelines those
managed to stand out as fitting with
this theme there's another one of those
promotional Flyers out there and it has
a VHS tape a teddy bear and what I
presume are moose tracks the tracks are
probably related to Nat going out and
trying to find this moose again as I
mentioned in my episode 2 video that is
a lot of food and would probably get
them through the winter so it makes
sense that she might try to figure out
how to find this thing when I see a
teddy bear I Think of Laura Lee and we
know that adult Lottie has this
connection with her perhaps regrets that
she didn't follow her instincts and
believe in her vision and try to stop
her from flying the plane but we know
that she has Visions or at least had one
Vision where she saw her and it was
pretty frightening the BHS tape is
something that I don't have a great idea
about it could be related to adult van
so I'll mention it again when we get to
her the episode description reads relive
your youth by hitting the road take a
road trip with your child go on vacation
with a new friend hitchhike if you must
just make sure you pack a good playlist
for the ride some recommendations from
us anything you can do you get what you
give Instinct a famous composition by
Frank Comstock but absolutely not
anything from Starlight Express there's
a lot there but it sounds like that
everyone's going to be hitting the road
the mention of a child makes me think of
Shawna and Cali the new friend makes me
think of Misty and Walter hitchhike if
you must could be Nat trying to escape
or possibly tie if something happens
with her assistant's car in the trailer
it looks like van is fall following tie
again while she's sleepwalking and that
she walked to another tree that's marked
with the symbol Ty is wearing the same
headband as she was in the last episode
which made me wonder if that was a
flashback even though that would be a
weird way to open a trailer so I went
back and checked and Van is wearing
different clothes and if you look at the
two symbols side by side they're not
exactly the same so this is a different
night and it looks like she's going
straight to these symbols remember in
the first episode it looked like the man
with no eyes might be walking her off
that Cliff but after van tackled her we
saw that the symbol was there so he may
have been leading her to that that seems
more likely at this point this tells me
that the symbol will take on a new
meaning for the group and what's
interesting about these two figuring out
that that is where she goes whenever she
sneaks out is that they're gonna both
have different interpretations you hear
Vans say there's something deep inside
of you that's connected to all of this
she's looking for some higher meaning
she's trying to find answers there and
for from what we know about this
character that makes sense but from what
we know about Tai it would make sense
for her not to want to accept this and
instead look for a different explanation
that doesn't involve anything remotely
Supernatural and I'll come back to that
in one minute because we do see that
we're going to get our first glimpse of
van in the present day timeline she did
survive and there was a lot of news of
Lauren Ambrose being cast in the role in
the off season who you might know from
Six Feet Under or more recently servant
at the end of the last episode the bad
one sent Tai to find her and we'll get
to see how that plays out there isn't
much to go off in this trailer or any of
the previous ones it looks like she runs
or works at a shop where Ty will show up
there are posters on the wall and what
might be Collectibles or memorabilia all
around there's a lit sign behind her
with movie titles from the past which
makes it all feel nostalgic that's why I
was thinking the BHS tape might be
connected with her and it'll be
interesting to find out what's going on
here here because this all feels
somewhat disconnected from the other
survivors we've seen the idea of
nostalgia makes you think this series is
crafted in a way that looks back fondly
on this time period visually and
sonically but because of their
experiences the characters will never
look back at it in that same way unless
perhaps very specifically the time
before everything changed so I don't
know maybe where she's at is about being
stuck in the past longing for the time
before they got stranded in the
wilderness and became cannibals most of
what's been transpiring between tie and
band this season back in 96 has left me
wondering how to square adult ties
reactions to the things she's been doing
in the present day I guess two things to
consider are that not much time has
passed since she discovered the Altar
and she's mostly been trying to avoid
sleeping since that happened and that
it's implied that there was a long
period of time where she wasn't
sleepwalking at all otherwise it's hard
to figure out why she never address this
why she never tried to make sure that
she didn't start sleepwalking again what
we see with adult Lottie in the trailer
might go hand in hand with that we hear
her say I started having visions again
they need to stop and season one Ty said
that she started sleepwalking again when
she was talking to Shauna it seemed like
things were getting intense that they
were picking up again for Travis and the
time leading up to his death so this all
makes it feel like that there is
something happening right now where all
of these things are starting to happen
with more frequency at least we see
Lottie talking to a therapist and then
we see her cutting her Palm in the
wilderness and recreating that in the
present day this seems like she's trying
to spill blood like she's trying to
invoke a vision possibly after seeing
the symbol that she put on Shauna's
blanket get the blood on it and then the
birds falling from the sky we've seen
shots in the trailer where she's
touching a tree and that is probably got
the symbol on it and to put it in her
terms this seems like an offering in her
shots we also see a queen of hearts with
the eyes marked out this is something
that shows up in the season 2 opening
credits with a note that says I'm
grateful for my friends and it makes me
think about the fact that Nat said that
there were no queens in the deck inside
the cabin also when they sent misty out
to get water they said that she had
drawn a four so it seems like they
decide some things by drawing cards how
that connects to the queens and why they
weren't there before or whatever is
undetermined but there's also another
shot in the season two trailer where we
see Natalie burning a card in the
present day and it stands out that she's
wearing heliotrope there so this is
further on in the season somewhere
because everything we've seen so far
she's still wearing that same outfit she
was wearing when they abducted her the
running theory about the cards is that
they'll be used to pick their victims
when they get to the point where they
have to sacrifice each other when things
get really bad like you know the pit
Girl scene not really sure what that
says about the Queens in the deck Lottie
did tell Nat a fascinating story about
queen bees in episode three so I'm
curious to see where this is all going
does her blood offering produce a vision
or maybe just a hallucination it sure
looks like it to me there's this shot
where she appears to be indoors in a
shopping center or something along those
lines and of course the big WTF moment
where they show her descending into an
underground bunker or tunnel or if you
watch the series Lost a hatch a lot of
people are wondering if this is
connected to finding Javi since it looks
like a place that if you really wanted
to believe it was out there in the
wilderness you could probably talk
yourself into it and there are lights
which could be a sign of a power source
and Provisions to keep someone alive I
mean this could turn out to be the case
but I think it's unlikely because the
other shots the ones that look like a
shopping mall seem completely unrelated
to where they are currently plus the
Visions she's had in the last two
episodes that she's talking about
wanting to stop all of that leads me to
believe it's all part of a larger Vision
something that only exists in her mind
and maybe it's hitting towards something
but we'll have to wait and see on that
there's one other shot of Nat and Lottie
at her compound where it looks like
she's been invited inside her living
quarters can't really see what's going
on other than that is sort of peeking
around the door frame while lottie's
walking around in her room elsewhere
there's a quick shot of Misty and Walter
on their road trip where he says he
doesn't care if she's a yellow jacket
presumably they're on their way to
lottie's compound in this and he's
already suspect but the way he says it
was 30 years ago like where he makes
that mistake that kind of stands out it
seems a little odd and I'm not buying
that someone who calls themselves a
citizen detective isn't interested in
what has to be one of the biggest news
stories in that area in his lifetime as
we saw in the first season everyone that
meets these people once to know what
really happened out there and I just
don't see why Walter would be any
different in another shot we hear Cali
say she's so over secrets and there's a
couple of shots of Shawna and Jeff at
home that don't really get much away I
don't really have anything to add it
just seems like that story is going on
its current trajectory so we'll see what
that's all about two shots that are
probably connected involve the frozen
lake and the first one you see Nat
looking at something under the ice the
shot comes from below so you get the
idea that there's something there that
she's looking at and in the second one
we see Travis holding on to her where it
looks like he's saving her after she
fell in and there are several other
characters watching there had been a
shot of someone inside the water in the
official trailer and I guess now we can
say that's not I don't know what she
would see that would make her want to
put herself in this position or why
they're all there together since they're
always on the brink of starving a food
source comes to mind but fishing wasn't
a big thing when the weather was good so
I don't know why it would be now it's
probably something else and going after
it put her in a bad position obviously
we know she survives so they save her
but one thing I saw people guess might
be happening here is that she could lose
their only gun if she fell in
unexpectedly there's a promo photo of
Ben handing her a hatchet but she still
has the rifle in that shot but either
way no gun would make everything a lot
harder it might explain why they're
using pungy sticks by the time they get
around to killing the pit girl I guess
this trip might be a parallel for a lot
he's tripped Into the Wilderness to
produce a vision because I expect there
will be a lot of back and forth based on
their different beliefs as to how they
can get through the crisis there is an
enclosed shot of mari's face that makes
me think about her hearing the dripping
sound and that's about it for what's in
the trailer two other things to mention
about the promo photos first there are a
lot of shots of Ben up and around
talking to the group so it doesn't look
like he was on his deathbed in the last
episode or if he was he's recovered
somehow the other one that caught my I
was Van looking at the map he was making
with Nat in the opening credits you see
a shot of that with the symbol laid over
it and now that sleepwalking Ty has been
taking her to spots where the symbol is
carved in trees maybe she's starting to
put that all together and I think that's
probably a good place to leave things
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon